[موسيقى]
كنت خاف انه انا يصير لي شي
ومحمود كيف بده ياكل ما هو ما بيعرف يقول
ياكل انا انا بدي اكل ما بقول انا عطشان
انا بروح بشربه بس انا الشيء اللي مقلقني
ولعطلت همه محمود طلع منه الحمد لله
اوقات الدنيا بتوجعني
[موسيقى]
بتعاند وياي
لا بخاف وحاخاف ازاي يعني
دايما مطمن طول ما انت معايا
بعض الاحيان فكرت بالانتحار بعض الاحيان
كنت اتمنى الموت انا وابني لانه انا موتي
انا ما رح يجيب نتيجه بالنهايه ابن رحيضل
لحاله وهيدا مش الشي اللي انا بدي اياه
فانا لما حسيت اني انا خلاص ذوقت وذرعا
بيقولوا خلاص ما عاد بقى قادره اتحمل هيدي
الفاتن النكديه والاكتئاب والحزن
بلشت بقى
ابحث عن حلول نفسيه فرحت درست سايكو دراما
لانه انا كنت مقتنعه انه انا مش رح يمشي
حالي بجلسه وجلستين ولا سنه وسنتين انا
مقتنعه انه انا بحاجه اني انا اعرف كيف
اتعامل مع مشاعري وافهم نفسيتي
لكل العمر لانه انا عارفه الوضع اللي انا
فيه حرافقني كل العمر
[موسيقى]